[Music]
anyone familiar with the work of
director David Cronenberg knows that he
has an intense fascination with bodies
physical bodies bodies transformed or
bodies mutilated bodies dripping or
bodies exploded so it's no surprise that
his film Eastern Promises opens with a
focus on three bodies the sliced body of
a Chechen gangster the wounded expiring
body of a pregnant prostitute and the
fragile small body of that woman's
infant who is soaked in her blood it
will eventually become clear that these
three bodies are connected by the film's
narrative a point that has made explicit
early on by one character's poor grasp
of English their secret budgies body
indeed it is a central theme of
Cronenberg that bodies only exist within
a continuum of other bodies to which
they are connected and from which they
gain meaning for Cronenberg the body is
representative of the individual perhaps
even more so than the mind despite the
fact that war mental creatures
conceiving of things in abstraction we
are irrevocably tied to the physical
organism that's given to us and much of
our anxiety about ageing or disease or
deformity is directed toward the body in
Eastern Promises the physical reality of
the body is examined in the context of
the equally physical reality of
collective violence of which bodies are
its perpetrators and victims now
Cronenberg only has a few scenes that
actually show that violence I think 5 in
total but their presence saturates the
rest of the film and your lingering
memories of it take the very first scene
the throat slitting the way it's filmed
you're not allowed any distance from the
action you're right there your own neck
feels sensitive your own hand feels like
it's holding the knife
Cronenberg is a genius at placing the
audience in the middle of body on body
clashes like this one the violence is
literally embodied by the viewer but
before I get too far ahead of myself
Eastern Promises tells the story of the
expatriate Russian mafia in London and
the ripples that run through it when a
midwife played by Naomi Watts uncovers a
diary with potentially damaging evidence
against the family connected to this is
the story of Nikolai played expertly by
Viggo Mortensen a driver slash thug
whose ruthlessness judgment and
efficiency propels him up the ranks of
the crime organization that organization
and the Russian crime world in general
is evidenced on individual members by
tattoos that tell the story of their
lives and their rank emphasizing the
real bodily relationship between
individuals and the group who have
tattoos you don't exist as well as a
captain this body this corpse who the
audience knows was professionally
processed by nikolai earlier in the film
sets up an interesting contrast because
of that processing the police can't
identify the individual only that
individuals rank and history of crime
here's an example of how individuality
is sacrificed to the collective most
groups and especially those that use
violence as a means organize themselves
around some kind of common ideal some
code or tradition of scoid code says
never speak to anybody about you'll get
the same individuals it's often
hypothesize need a shared code like this
to commit acts of cruelty because in a
group those acts can be attributed to
the collective and its goals and the
individual doesn't have to face
responsibility or individuality is it I
think this makes for a paradox and a
problem the paradox is that collectives
often ask people to relinquish
individuality but the thing that defines
individuality and identity for so many
people is their place within a
collective more on that in a moment
the problem is that once a person
sacrifices part of his or her
individuality to the group
group can then sacrifice the individual
Tatiana the pregnant woman from the
beginning of the film whose voiceover
diary entries hang like a spectre over
everything that happens left Russia to
find a better life in the multicultural
collective of London but she was
absorbed into a vicious subgroup of that
collective that sacrificed her
individuality for its own ends
Anna the midwife wants to connect with
her Russian heritage but she too brings
herself within the orbit of the Mafia
escaping where Tatiana could not the
head of the Mafia's son played by
vincent cassell is genetically linked to
his group started [__] birth mock me
which means he has to sacrifice his
homosexuality his individual truth to an
organization and a culture that rejects
such a lifestyle at the risk of being
ostracized or worse it's worth noting of
course that Cronenberg uses this case to
highlight the way men use their bodies
to project masculinity real or fake of
course the major case study here is that
of Nikolai Nikolai sacrifices himself to
the Russian mafia made perfectly clear
by the way he prefers his naked body to
the group and the ritual almost errata
sized scene in which he earns the star
tattoos
almost immediately after this he learns
the cost of that sacrifice when he is
betrayed this isn't only one of the best
fight scenes in film history beautifully
choreographed and filmed but it's the
scene that brings all of kronenberg's
themes to a climax this matrix of
individual collective body and violence
individuals subsumed in groups like the
Russian mafia are in a strange kind of
crisis the group doesn't so much demand
the disillusion of individuality but
rather the maintenance of an
individuality that's always united with
the group's intentions it's easy to see
how paradoxical that is how can
individuals define themselves by
connection to an organization that makes
them interchangeable in the bathhouse
scene the Russian mob uses this
interchangeability to betray Nikolai
letting the Chechens identify him as
someone else by his tattoos of course
the tattoos are a form of body
manipulation that individuals like
Nikolai used to code this paradoxical
identity into reality to make it real a
Cronenberg and Mortensen have Nicolai
fight naked in order to show that by
joining this group it's not only
individuality that's made vulnerable but
the body itself and when it's revealed
finally that Nikolai is actually an
undercover agent
it's these cuts and bruises that prove
his devotion to another kind of
collective the police and realized his
identity as a hero who uses the rules of
individuals and groups to his own
advantage
the Cronenberg is a master filmmaker
because he can use the elements of a
crime genre film written by someone else
to interrogate these big themes human
beings are individuals in collectives
they are minds and bodies they operate
within ideas where blood is symbolic
just a color or a bouquet of roses and
yet live in the physical world where
blood can send you to jail or be the
last thing you ever see among these
themes are paradoxes that we can't
resolve but our bodies expose a truth
that David Cronenberg wants us to
remember that we are all the victims and
the perpetrators of reality
hey everybody thanks for watching if you
like this video and you want to see more
like it more from the nerd rider you can
pledge to my channel by clicking right
here and going to my patreon page those
people just pledged like a dollar or
three dollars but that really makes this
whole channel possible these videos take
a long time to make and you guys are
what enables this channel to keep going
so thank you thank you thank you thank
you for that I love this movie I think
this is just a great example of an
amazing director elevating a genre movie
to become something more than that by by
the power of his directing what he
chooses to focus on and the themes that
he laces through it so I love Cronenberg
I might analyze more of his movies I
don't know but this is a fantastic one I
think uncle Mortensen so I will see you
guys next Wednesday